hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to mind your decisions
here's a fun problem for the upcoming pi
day
the square root of p i plus e is equal
to the square root of p i e
solve if each letter is a different
digit from 0 to 9 but p is not equal to
0.
note p i is a 2-digit number and p-i-e
is a 3-digit number
you're not allowed to use calculators to
solve this problem
i thank mun and shaw who listed this
problem on his website math misery
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
so how can we solve this problem
there are many ways to approach it but
i'm just going to present one solution
so the first thing is we want pi to be a
perfect square
so we can enumerate all of the cases
where we have a two-digit perfect square
next we need a three-digit number that's
a perfect square
so we'll enumerate all of these options
furthermore we need the first two digits
of this number to also be a perfect
square
so we can see we have one example in 169
where 16 is the first two digits and we
can go through all of the other cases
so we end up with exactly three
possibilities
we now need to check if these will work
for our equation
so we can compute these examples and it
turns out only the first case is valid
and that's our solution
p is equal to 1 i is equal to 6 and e is
equal to 9.
did you figure it out
thanks for watching
these math videos available for free on
youtube build confidence for students
and inspire mathematical discovery for
viewers around the world they have over
100 million views and the channel has
over 1 million subscribers please
subscribe for free to get the newest
videos and email me a puzzle or math
topic
mindyourdecisions.com if you so choose
you can check out my merchandise on
teespring you can check out my books
which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon thanks for watching and thanks
for your support